The Joe Rogan Experience is an exciting
time for the welterweight division too
you know with you having that uh beef
with Leon and Leon now having retained
the title and they're talking about
Colby but I feel like with a good
showing against Gilbert used to skip the
line yeah yeah it becomes and Leon wants
it you know more than anything he wants
it more than anything just for the
history that we have and also we're
going to sell the most pay-per-views if
if me and him are in that cage it'll
sell a lot yeah it'll sell a lot it'll
be a big fight it's going to be a
gigantic fight what did you think about
the rematch the the rubber fight with uh
Leon and Camaro uh little lackluster you
know and um Usman uh
maybe like there was times where I
didn't see him like stepping on the gas
like it usually does you know and it
might have been because he just took
this fight too early I always think that
when a fighter gets knocked out you you
really you know and I got this from like
the old timers unboxing you need to
really let your brain and your
confidence like heal and come back you
know because then you get back in and
you get touched and you're like whoa I
might get knocked out and you pull the
the brakes and you start like you know
maybe second guessing yourself so I
think maybe he took it a little bit too
early you know I I do think that uh
he's a in a way better fighter than neon
in a lot of aspects but Leon just has
his number it seems right now but Leon
was also super confident coming into
that fight you know I feel like once a
guy becomes the champion they they gain
confidence and they gain ability because
they just have this understanding of
what they're capable of doing and the
fact that it was in England
it was it was and he had the title and
he knocked him out yeah all the above a
lot of factors you just don't know how a
guy's gonna come back after his first KO
loss and it was a battle it was a brutal
one usoman was down for a bit how long
after the Camaro fight did you take off
uh close to like eight to nine months or
more maybe maybe even longer you know
all my coaches wanted me plus um it was
like the first Chao of my career you
know so Marshall and like not not my
body was already healed my brain but
they wanted to make sure that my mind
was right you know yeah
how long did it take you to get over it
um I still haven't got over it brother I
I want to [__] rip usman's [__]
brains out you know nothing personal I
just want to get back in there and do it
to him you know I've never been knocked
down and I've fought in a lot you know
we were talking about earlier Eaves
Edwards like I find great Strikers you
know and they never even came close to
knocking me out and it's not the
disusement but he's not I don't put him
in the league of one of these great
strikes he's a great fighter because he
could do a lot of things well but after
fighting him the first time and getting
his best shots and I cut 20 pounds of
water and I took the fight in six day
notice and I went to Abu Dhabi I was
like bro this guy will never hurt me
like he he hits like a [__] and then
all of a sudden he's a dude that knocks
man I had five rounds with him so for in
that I think it was nine months since
the first fight did he gain that type of
powers just nuts to me you know it was
like unreal unnatural you know because I
I felt his [__] best punches in the
first fight for five rounds and never
hurt me never like Shook Me Up good you
know and then boom surprise hit in the
second fight so do you think it was a
matter of you not respecting his power
as and on top of that him just getting
better I I always respect anybody has
two hands and two feet so it's not like
I'm I'm trying to do like touch me in
the chain and I'll give a shot to take a
shot definitely caught me by surprise
when when he when he started to load up
I kind of saw like the back of his head
so I thought for sure he's gonna shoot
so I started to like drop my hands and I
noticed like Midway oh it's her right
hand I try to check hook him but it's
too late already that the right hand
already penetrated the force field and
took my ass out you know
yeah it's uh it's a moment that happens
to many fighters and it defines who they
are how they bounce back from it yeah
you know oh and I'm coming I'm I'm
coming strong man I feel
um my mind after that fight maybe uh I'm
not gonna lie I went into like a dark
place for a while because like I said
I've never been knocked out it was just
[__] nuts to me like bro this guy's
the one that [__] literally knocked
me out like I was out cold it wasn't
like a like you stopped it earlier
nothing I know in my heart of hearts
just got [__] knocked me out and for
me to to think usman's the one that
knocked me out I never would have bet it
that this guy would knock me out so
it uh it affected me bro I'm bad you
know what I'm saying do you ever go to a
sports psychologist
um
I just listened to Jordan Peterson on
YouTube man that's my dude right there
for many many years I I've never met him
I haven't got a chance but I'm actually
um by coincidence he's in Florida April
9th and I'm like doing everything in my
power to make sure that I'm there like
right after my fight I'm gonna go he's
gonna have a conference down enough I'll
connect you guys oh hell yeah yeah I'll
connect you guys yeah for sure he's
gonna be in Florida so I was like bro I
gotta go there I just want to sit in the
crowd and listen to this dude I've been
listening to him for years on like
YouTube and stuff